willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es um einen ganz interessanten
philosophen nämlich um johann gottlieb
fichte und sein begriff des bösen die
autogeschichte lebte ende des 18
jahrhunderts anfang des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts und so sah der gute mann
aus und er hat eine schrift verfasst
nämlich die system der sittenlehre von
1798 zu fürchten muss man sagen dass er
ganz stark von immanuel kant geprägt war
dann mache ich auch oben rechts sind in
youtube den link zur letzten sitzung
rhein wo es um ganz begriff des bösen
ging richtig nervt ganz stark an cantz
moralphilosophie an
aber er geht auch noch ein bisschen
weiter und wir haben jetzt eben unseren
paar leitfragen überlegt zunächst wie
knüpft sich die ein kampfbegriff des
bösen an es geht vor allem um ist böse
nicht so sehr um das gute warum können
wir nachrichten nicht das böse und des
bösen willen tun das hatte eben auch
kant vertreten diese these im gegensatz
zu augustinus in seinen beispiel des
dünnen diebstahls mache ich auch oben
rechts und links augustinus hatte ja
bekanntlich die these vertreten wir
können das böse und des bösen willen tun
wir können stehen einfach nur um zu
stehen hat das wasser diese theorie von
augustinus ja wie knüpft fichte an
leibnitz begriff der trägheit an um das
böse zu bestimmen sie nennen sich auch
noch leibnitz hat gesagt das böse
besteht in der idealen natur des
menschen verstanden als mahnung mit der
physik um die endlichkeit und auch der
trägheit wie ein schiff im strom des
guten sich erst mit dem strom widersetzt
dann war auch oben rechts den link zu
leiten
und dann hatte ich noch einen
interessanten begriff geprägt nämlich
den des schlimm trias der schlendrian
also die versteht fichten den
schlendrian vielleicht haben sie sich
schon mal gehört schlendrian was das ist
hört man ab und zu das vielleicht nicht
mehr so häufig gebräuchlich dieses wort
wie der liegt darauf wie werden begriff
mit dem bösen in eine verbindung zu
bringen und das wohlwollen man es
genauer anschauen wie das böse als
schlendrian als als schlamperei als ja
als trägheit zu verstehen ist man könnte
ja denken
schlamperei und trägheit ist was was
irgendwie nicht ganz aktiv ist in dem
endlosen sind wir irgendwie passiv oder
mangelhaft oder so das meint fichte
nichts und fichte wie wir gleich sehen
werden meint dass das böse immer auch
mit einer aktivität zu tun hat also im
bösen sind wir selbst ganz schön clever
und
durchtrieben könnte man sagen ja also
jetzt sagt er hier folgendes in diesem
system der sittenlehre es lässt sich
zwar wohl vorher sehen und
begreifen
dass der mensch auf dem niedrigen
reflexion punkten eine zeitlang oder
auch wohl sein ganzes leben verweilen
werde das schlecht nichts gibt das in
höhe treiben und die erfahrung besteht
bestätigt wenigstens das erste als
allgemein insofern ist in das böse
angeboren hang zum bösen radikal böse
bekannt aber es ist doch nicht notwendig
dass er darauf diesem reflexion punktes
lösen stehen bleiben da es auch nichts
gibt das sind auf denselben zurückhalte
es ist ihm ebenso möglich sich zugleich
auf den höchsten punkt zu versetzen und
wenn er das nicht getan hat so liegt
dies am nichtgebrauch ist seiner
freiheit ob er gleich in seinem
gegenwärtigen zustand seiner
verschuldung sich nicht frust wird
insofern hat das böse menschen zahlen
grund in der freiheit das ist ziemlich
genau das was auch immanuel kant gesagt
das böse betrifft uns alle
es ist uns angeboren aber es ist nicht
notwendig sondern ist nur subjektiv
notwendig dass hatte kant gesagt das
böse ist subjektiv notwendig und fichte
versucht das jetzt auf eine andere weise
darzustellen er sagt nämlich dass es
etwas mit unserer reflexion zu tun hat
und darin geht er über kant hinaus also
wir sind dann böse wir handeln land böse
wenn wir auf eine weise reflektieren die
uns nicht mehr moralisch sensibel werden
lässt für die gebote des gesetzes
weiter geht es ist schlechthin unmöglich
und widersprechen sagt pflichtet dass
jemand bei dem deutlichen bewusstsein
seiner pflicht im augenblick des handels
mit guten bewusstsein sich entschließen
seine pflicht nicht zu tun dass er gegen
das gesetzlich empörend ihm den gehorsam
verweigere und es sich zur maxime machen
nichts zu tun war seine pflicht ist
darum weile seine pflicht ist eine
solche maxime wäre teuflisch aber dem
griff des teufels widerspricht sich
selbst und hebt so nach sich auf sie
hören sich an cancan hatte auch gesagt
das böse um des bösen wir tun können wir
nicht das können wir nicht das wäre ein
teuflischer wille das geht nicht und
wichtig künftig genau an also wieder
gegen augustinus wir können das böse
nicht um des bösen willen tun warum es
wäre ein widerspruch die vernunft
gebietet das gute zu tun und wir können
nicht mit der vernunft gegen die
fahndung konnte das ist überhaupt die
frage ob das vielleicht nicht doch
möglich ist wir haben genug fälle in den
medien usw wo wir menschen erleben die
offenbar das böse und des bösen willen
ton häufig sagen wir dann diese menschen
sind psychisch krank
das ist immer die frage wenn wir sagen
die menschen psychisch krank dann
entlasten wir sie dann sagen wir sie
sind gar nicht wirklich verantwortung
zeigen dazu menschen die das böse um das
bösen willen tun für psychisch nicht
zurechnungsfähig zu halten aber es gibt
sicherlich menschen die das auch tun
aber wir haben dann immer so den
eindruck die können nicht recht bei
trost zahlen wer wirklich bei recht bei
trost ist dann würde das böse geht um
das böse der würde vielleicht immer gute
gründe anführen und sagen ich mache doch
eigentlich nur das gut ja und so ist
geschichte und jetzt will er das
beweisen hier beweisen die ist dass der
mensch nicht das böse um das böse für
ihn tun kann folgendermaßen der mensch
ist sich seiner pflicht klar bewusst
heißt er als intelligenz fordert von
sich schlechthin etwas zu tun
entschließt sich mit guten bewusstsein
gegen seine pflicht zu handeln heißt
erfordert von sich demselben ungeteilten
momente dasselbe nicht zu tun es wären
so nach indem selber momente durch
dasselbe vermögen in ihm widersprechende
forderung welche voraussetzung sich
selbst vernichtet und der klarste offen
baust widersprach ist
also wenn der menschlich seiner pflicht
klar bewusst ist was das sittengesetz
gebietet wer dann fordert er von sich
selbst etwas zu tun
also nämlich das was das sieben gesetzen
empfiehlt unsere vernunft sagt uns wir
sollen so und so handeln jetzt kann er
aber nach fichte wenn ihm die vernunft
gebietet das sittengesetz nicht gleich
sich mit guten bewusstsein also mit
klarem bewusstsein gegen seine pflicht
handeln sonst würde er nämlich in sich
zwei momente desselben vermögens finden
nämlich einmal das für einmal die
normativität ist eben gesetzt unser
vermögen der fonds zeigt wir sollen gut
handelt und zugleich würden wir durch
die vernunft gegen die vernunft und wir
würden in der vernunft uns zu sprechen
also können wir nicht bei klarem
bewusstsein also mit vernunft gegen die
vernunft handel
ja was aber wie können wir dann das böse
erklären er sagt es ist sehr möglich
dass man das klare bewusstsein der
anforderung der pflicht ihn sich für
dunkle nehmen alle praktisch nicht ein
gutes bewusstsein hat sondern ein also
kein klares bewusstsein mehr hat zwar
nur ein verdunkelt das bewusstsein
nämlich durch eine nackte absoluten
spontanität entsteht jenes bewusstsein
und nur durch fortsetzung jenes aktie
frei bleibt es hört man auf zu
reflektieren so verschwindet ist
also das ist der punkt also das
sittengesetz
existiert nur so lange wie wir uns auf
das konzentrieren
wenn wir nicht mehr auf das sittengesetz
reflektieren dann verdunkelt
sich dann bemerkten wir dass
sittengesetz nicht mehr in uns und dann
haben wir die möglichkeit ihm zuwider zu
handeln dann haben wir kein gutes
bewusstsein mit der pflicht sondern wir
verdunkeln durch reflexion unser
bewusstsein der pflicht und das kennen
sie alle man kann nicht immer wieder
ausreden überlegen man kann sich ja in
eine reflexive distanz bringen zur
moralischen dingen man kann sich ein
gutes gewissen auch einreden das geht
alles man kann auch sein leben auf
solche lügen sondieren ob das dann
irgendwann
zusammenbricht ist die andere frage aber
es geht also um eine verdunkelung
die sache verhält sich die nach so wird
auf die vorder und in form des gesetzes
das sittengesetz vorder und reflektiert
so bleibt sie uns vor augen so ist es
unmöglich nicht nach ihr zu handeln wenn
wir das sittengesetz klar vor augen
haben sagt fichte sagt auch kann können
wir nicht gegen der sittengesetz handeln
in beiden fällen also herrscht
notwendigkeit
das ist das problem ein anderer geht
sagte dieses system das man sagt nur
notwendigkeit wir können gar nicht böse
handelt weil entweder wir sehen das
sittengesetz in uns dann können wir
nicht böse handeln wenn man es nicht und
sehen dann haben wir einfach einen
mangel an vernunft dann sind wir einfach
determiniert name einfach nur
notwendigkeit das sagt fichte geht nicht
und jetzt ist ganz wichtig die wichtige
einsicht dass das sittengesetz gar
nichts etwas ist was ohne alles zu tun
und sei sind dass es erst durch uns
selbst gemacht hat das sittengesetz
zumindest seine präsenz wird erst durch
uns selbst präsent aber im gegenwärtigen
system
dauert das bewusstsein dass sie entweder
fort und dann bewirkt es notwendig die
moralische handlung in diesem
deterministischen system oder es
verschwindet und dann ist ein
moralisches handeln
das ist ein fatalismus ja also nach
diesen drei zugesagten können wir
entweder gar nicht gegen das
sittengesetz handeln weil wir es ja
immer vor augen haben oder wir können
wir handeln dagegen aber nur deswegen
weil wir es nicht uns verspüren und dann
werden wir ja auch nicht dafür zu rächen
wir müssen immer um zu recht sein so
seien für das böse das sittengesetz auch
in uns irgendwann nehmen können und
jetzt sagt ich hätte anschein des
fatalismus verschiedene zugleich wenn
man darauf mehr dass er darauf acht gibt
dass es ja von unserer freiheit abhänge
ob jenes bewusstsein das sind 1 gesetzes
vorteile oder sich für dunkle und das
ist der entscheidende punkt es hängt von
uns selbst ab ob das sittengesetz vor
unseren augen steht oder nicht wenn wir
nicht das sittengesetz wahrnehmen hat es
nichts damit zu tun dass wir es nicht
wahrnehmen können oder wie es einfach
gar nicht spüren können sondern sind wir
selbst die ursache dafür dass wir es
nicht waren im test eingesetzt und
dadurch kann jetzt wichtig zeigen dass
wir auch dann freise wenn wir uns
moralisch handeln der grund des
unmoralischen handel besteht nach
wichtig darin unsere einsicht in die
moralität selbst zu verdunkeln und
selbst zu belügen das machen wir ja
immer wieder jeder von uns verändert man
merke man wohl dass auch dieser akt der
freiheit durch welchen man jenes
bewusstsein das sittengesetz in wieder
klar erhält oder das verdunkeln lässt
ein absolut erst dann unerklärliche akt
ist nämlich ist geschieht nicht etwa
nach einer maxime als mit dem
bewusstsein dessen was ich tue und der
freiheit welche ich es tue dass sich die
anforderung des gesetzes in ihr für
dunkle dies wäre die oben als
widersprechend aufgezeigt empörung
wieder das gesetz das geht nicht das
sagt augustinus gesagt wir können uns
nicht gegen das gesetz das hat gerade
augustinus gesagt dass wir gegen das
gesetz und empören das geht nach kant
fichte nicht ja das ist also jeder punkt
weiter unten zeigte das verschwinden das
sittengesetz geredet wird ist eine
abstraktion von der letzteren art ein
unbestimmtes denken dass gegen die
pflicht läuft in dem wir das bestimmt
bewusstsein der pflicht selbst pflicht
ist das entscheiden also wie kommen wir
jetzt dazu dass das verschwinden des der
pflicht in uns auftritt da sagt richtet
das verschwinden des bewusstseins der
pflicht ist eine abstraktion von der wii
abstrahieren also von der konkreten
pflicht abstrahieren heißt einfach sich
lösen von der pflicht
etwas anderes denken
das sittengesetz nicht mehr ganz ernst
nehmen das ist der grund wir
abstrahieren und der pflicht
wir tauschen uns dann selbst über das
was unsere pflicht ist und handel wie
man gewöhnlich sagt aus einem irrenden
gewissen aber diese irrtum ist so bleibt
unsere schuld hätten wir unsere einzigen
die pflicht die schon da war
festgehalten und das hängt natürlich
auch von uns zur freiheit so hätten wir
nicht gehört es waltet hier ein sehr
gefährlicher selbstbetrug gegen welchem
man auf seinem hut zu sein sehr nötig
hat wenn wir nur ehrlich zu werke gehen
sage ich sie eben denn es ist sehr wohl
möglich dass jemand nur anderen
vorspielen spiegele er tue als pflicht
worüber er selbst volker weiß das ist
das eignet tut und das ist die pflicht
von ihm gar nicht fordert und da sehr
ungepflegt sich gar nicht gekümmert weil
er etwa ein dogmatisch ungläubige ist
ein solcher ist ein grober heuchler und
gehört nicht in die gegenwärtige klassen
also es geht darum dass wir uns selbst
täuschen über das was unsere pflicht ist
mit täuschens nicht aber so dass wir
einfach einen irrtum unterliegen weil
wir vielleicht zu dumm sind sollen nach
fichte sind wir selbst schuld wenn wir
uns über die geltung des gesetzes dran
weil wir uns irgendwie ihren wollen und
dem amerikaner spricht hier von einer
schuld des irrtums das macht kann auch
in anderen kontexten wir sind nach kant
immer selbst schuld wenn wir uns irren
der grund liegt in uns selbst und nicht
in der beschränkung unserer vermögen und
so sitzt eben auch im nordischen region
aus ja das ist also hier das
entscheidende dass man
glaubt dass man sich vom zittern gesetz
lösen könne er sagt weiter endlich ist
die anforderung der pflicht ihrer form
nach als pflicht bestimmt sie verlangt
schlechterdings und mit dem nachsitzung
alle antriebe gehör sagt das war die
unterordnung der selbstliebe unter das
sittengesetz bekannt lässt man diese
bestimmtheit in sich verdunkeln sich
dunkel werden zu erscheinen uns das
pflicht geburt nicht mehr als gebot
sondern nur etwa als gute rat die man
folgen könne wenn es uns beliebt und
nicht so viel verleugnung kostet den
mann wo allenfalls sich auch etwas
abbringen lasse man macht in diesem
zustände sich eine gemischte maxime geht
nicht jedem allenthalben auf den größten
genuss aus und fragt nun nach ihm
bescheidet sich viel mehr hier und da
auch seine pflicht und müssen opfert der
pflicht etwa diejenigen genüsse auf die
uns außerdem nicht reizen der
verschwender die geilste er süchtige
liste den um seine ehre bringen können
behält sich aber diejenigen vor die uns
die liebsten sind noch zu einem vertrag
zwischen dem gewissen und er regiert und
glaubt sie mit beiden zugleich
abgefunden zu haben diese denkart ist es
nicht recht frech vorgibt man könne
nicht zu leben wie es das gesetz
verlange die tödliche ausübung derselben
sei unmöglich ein vorgeben das sind
gemein lebens sehr häufig ist das ich
aber von ihm auch in philosophische und
theologische system eingeschlichen hat
also der punkt ist hier nicht sagt wir
reagieren auf die absolute pflicht des
gesetzes der kategorische imperativ
gebietet ja ohne ausnahme kategorisch so
dass wir sagen wir können diesem
sittengesetz gar nicht wollen das
sittengesetz ist zu streng der sitten
gesetzes unmenschlich das sieht ein
gesetz verlangt zu viel von uns und
deswegen nehme ich mir die freiheit in
manchen punkten mal gegen das gesetz zu
verstoßen erlaube ich mir manche hassen
das sittengesetz das ist nicht adäquat
da bin ich völlig überfordert und das
nein der fichte also seien ein guter rat
kann man sagen dass das sittengesetz
schon gut
heissen situation ist es wirklich gut
ist ein guter ratschlag so was du nicht
willst was man dir tu das füg auch
keinem andern zu so das ok aber in
manchen punkten ist es echt viel zu
stark viel zu streng das nicht adäquat
und das meint jetzt hier eben fichten ja
also ein vertrag zwischen dem gewissen
integrieren sagt also ich brauche
einfach von meinem eine gute entwicklung
traurig einfach auch manchmal eine
situation wo ich nicht auf sieben
gesetzten muster das ist sonst wäre ja
fix und fertig das stresst nicht dass im
gesetz stresst nicht und stress ist
moralisch nicht gut also darf ich
manchem 7 gesetz nicht gehorchen so das
wäre dieser vertrag kann das auch das
vernünftig da suchen wir gründe um uns
aus diesem strengen geburt das
sittengesetz was er kategorisch gilt
alle fälle in allen situationen zu
entlassen also das ist ein argument das
sittengesetz ist viel zu stressig das
stresst mich nackig stresssymptome und
stress ist ungesund und tut mir nicht
gut und was wir nicht gut tut ist an ich
kann nicht moralisch gut sein also darf
ich mir manchmal ausnahme erlaubt von
dem gesetz
das wäre so ein argument
und man könnte sagen das sittengesetz
ist unmenschlich das hat ja kein
erbarmen mit mir ich bin doch nur ein
endliches wesen wieso sollte ich hier
moralisch perfekt handeln kann doch kein
mensch tun so das sagt sich das ist
gerade der anfang vom bösen wenn wir so
denken aber ich denke jeder von uns
kennt solche gedanken also dann will
sich immer irgendwie so ausnahmen
erlauben das heißt beim schwarzfahren
sei es woanders ja also ist nur
menschlich dass wir so
ersetzte so nach eine ursprüngliche
trägheit zur reflexion seitlich und was
daraus folgt zum handeln nach dieser
reflexion voraus dies wäre es nach ein
wahres positives radikales übel nicht
etwas nur negativ ist wie es bisher den
anschein gehabt hat so musste es denn
auch sagen wir müssen ein positives
haben um nur das negative erklären zu
können also dass radikale böse da hatte
immanuel kant darauf hingewiesen dass es
das gibt das ist wurzel haft löse das
ist also das was man nicht irgendwie nur
extrem ist im sinne des radikalismus
ganz einfach in uns verwurzelt eines
radwegs das sagt jetzt ich denn da geht
es über krankenhaus das liegt in unserer
ursprünglichen trägheit zu reflexion
also wir haben den hang zum bösen
bekannt hier haben wir den hang zur
trägheit wird also wir wollen
nachrichten immer wieder bestimmten
situation nicht weiter nachdenken wir
wollen einfach aufhören mit dem
nachdenken auf findet im prüfen unsere
maximen wie ich vorhin sagte das ist
doch unmenschlich das hält doch kein
mensch ausständig sich zu überprüfen
immer entspannen her ja so und das ist
diese trägheit reflexion die den grund
des bösen ausmacht wichtig ist jetzt
aber hierzu betont dass das böse nicht
mit der trägheit gleichzusetzen ist sein
dass die trägheit selbst grund einer
freien entscheidung ist ich entscheide
mich bewusst nicht mehr weiter meine
maxime zu prüfen weil ich mir
irgendwelche gründe gebe das ist zum
beispiel zu stressig für mich lässt und
dann folgt erst die trägheit aus aber
nicht so dass ich von anfang an träge
bin und deswegen nicht moralisch handel
weil dann könnte die trägheit ja
irgendwie auf natürliche defekte zurück
zu führen sein auf defekte die ich
selbst nicht zu verantworten haben nach
vicht wir müssen wir für die trägheit
selbst verantwortlich sein das heißt sie
muss einen freien anschluss folgen ja
und was berichtet uns zu einer solchen
voraussetzung ist es bloß die erfahrung
kann scheint dies anzunehmen ohne achtet
er übrigens derselbe folgend was wirst
du gleich folgen werden aber die bloße
erfahrung würde uns nicht zu einer so
allgemein voraus zum berechtigen es muss
danach wohl einfach nur und für jede
behauptung geben denn nur nicht etwa
natur notwendig keine zeugin dem dadurch
die freiheit aufgehoben würde sondern
nur jene allgemeinheit erfahrung
erklärte es muss ein vernunft grund
geben also wir müssen da rin frei sein
in dieser trägheit die zwischen führt
und jetzt sagt er im anschluss an
leibnitz folgendes der natur überhaupt
als solche ist eine kraft der trägheit
wie ist in rc sie kennen alle die in
sozial kraft an die sozialsysteme in der
physik wie es ist die kraft zu
verschreiben es gibt dies aus den
begriffe der wirksamkeit eines freien
wesens hervor dem notwendig in die zeit
fallen muss wenn sie wahr sein soll und
dies nicht könnte wenn sie nicht gesetzt
würde als durch die objekte aufgehalten
zwar scheint der begriff einer kraft der
trägheit widersprechen aber er ist
nichtsdestoweniger real es kommt nur
darauf an dass wir ihnen richtig fassen
natur als solche das nichtig und objekt
überhaupt hat nur ruhe nur sein sie ist
was ist und insofern ist hier gar keine
tätige kraft zuzuschreiben
also entscheiden ist hier dass sich das
sagt unser lösung kommt durch eine
trägheit zustande aber nicht eine
trägheit im sinne der inaktivität sind
als eine trägheit im sinne der kraft
sich zu widersetzen das ist entscheidend
und die plose natur die kann keine gerät
tätige kraft haben die natur als solches
sei es geht immer um uns selbst unsere
natur unser hang zum lösen der hatten
sich einen widerstreit an widerstreben
gegen die gebote des hätten besitzers
haben also dass sie einfacher sich durch
das sittengesetz eingeschränkt fühlen
dass die der sittengesetz für
unmenschlich hart erachten das ist
gerade die kraft der trägheit diese sind
gesetzt will sie aus ihrem ja
schlendrian seite sich gleich
herausbringen und dagegen haben sie was
das sind gesetzt das ist nicht ganz
kompatibel mit einer bequemen
lebensformen die sich irgendwie bequem
einrichtet in der welt das sittengesetz
das reizt und provoziert uns immer
wieder aufs neue und formuliert ja durch
den kategorischen imperativ 1 bei
fehlern uns der immer unangenehm für uns
sein kann unser gewissen macht sich
immer wieder bemerkbar
das ist alles andere als bequem kann
geht sogar soweit und sagt tut ist
moralische gesinnung im kampfe also nur
durch kampf sagt kann wirklich dann mit
unserem gewissen mit unserer einigung
mit unseren individuellen wünschen nur
dadurch indem er in diesem kampf die
oberhand
behalten und unsere individuellen
neigungen einschränken nur dadurch
können wir tugendhaft werden sagt kannte
das ist natürlich etwas ganz anderes als
eine bequeme haltung ja wo alles einfach
so wie gut läuft ja und jetzt geht
darauf ein auf diese falten getretene zu
allein lässt sich eine allgemeine
erscheinung in der menschheit erklären
über alles menschliche allein sicher
streckt die möglichkeit an gewöhnung und
der hang bei dem gewohnten zu bleiben
jeder mensch selbst bekräftigte und
tätigte hat sein schlendrian
wenn man erlaubt uns dieses niedrigen
aber sehr bezeichnen ausdrucks zu
bedienen und wird lebenslänglich gegen
ihn zu kämpfen haben dies ist die kraft
der trägheit unsere natur selbst die
regelmäßigkeiten ordnung der meisten
menschen ist nichts anderes als jener
hang zur ruhe und zum gewohnten das
kostet stets mühe sich loszureißen
gelingt es auch einmal und dauert die
erhalten erschütterung in einigen nach
links vorfeld der mensch sobald er
aufhört über sich selbst zu lachen gab
bald wieder in die gewohnte trägheit
zurück
also richtig sagt ganz bekannt moralität
ist nichts was irgendwie bequem ist was
was angenehm unbedingt ist was unbedingt
glück bedeutet die moral ist irgendwas
was auch immer uns produziert was uns
auch erniedrigt wir hatten das letzte
mal drüber diskutiert in dem gefühl der
achtung es erkannt verspüren wir auch
schmerz weil wir waren uns eigentlich
dünkel niedergeschlagen wird also moral
ist eine zweischneidige sache was unser
empfinden angelangt und wir neigen dazu
immer wieder uns bequem zu machen und
die moral hat eben nach cannes und auch
wichtig nichts mit bequemlichkeit zu tun
sind immer mit selbstüberprüfung mit
kritischer überwachung unserer maxime
sollen thema nennt testen das ist
natürlich eine situation die nicht immer
ganz angenehm ist das muss man ganz klar
sagen dass eine zumutung ist es ja eine
zumutung und gegen diese zumutung da
regt sich in uns wieder stand und dieser
widerstand ist der schlendrian wir
wollen nicht immer diese zumutung
erfahren wir wollen unseren gewöhnlichen
gang nehmen wo unsere eigenen trasse die
oberhand behalten track heizung nach
sichtet die durch lange gewohnheit sich
selbst ins unendliche reproduziert und
bald gänzliches unvermögen zum guten
wird ist das wahre angeboren in der
menschlichen natur selbst liegende
radikale über das ist es die trägheit
die gewissermaßen zur hexis nach
aristoteles die zur zweiten natur uns
geworden ist die ist eines eigentliche
radikale über weil wir dann nicht mehr
empfänglich werden für die gebote des
zweiten gesetzes weil wir uns dann
dagegen immunisieren und das sieht ein
gesetz davon abstrahieren und es - und
guten rat ansehen ja das kann man so
zusammenfassung dieser einheit alte
fichte versteht wie kann das böse als
anhang noch etwas radikales also wurzel
haftet wie kann kommentiert auch fichte
dass wir für das böse verantwortlich
sind und zwar maximal
wie kann so argumentiert auch richtet
das wir nicht direkt gegen das
sittengesetz handeln können das war
augoustinos etwas behauptet hat ficht
erklärt genauer als kann wie es dazu
kommt dass wir gegen das sittengesetz
handeln können nämlich durch die
verdunkelung durch die abstraktion des
vierten gesetzes das die präsentation
des hippen gesetzes und selbst
zurechenbar ist wie leibniz so bestimmt
auch fichte das böse als kraft der
trägheit und wichtigkeit regie das böse
im sinne einer lebensform als
schlendrian schlendrian ist diese ja
eine schlampige träge haltungen uns die
ja sich einfach auch widersetzt
gegenüber geboten wie etwa das
sittengesetz ja das war es für die
heutige sitzung der nächsten sitzung die
ersten zwei wochen stattfinden wird herr
nächste woche feine die veranstaltungen
aus da geht es dann um hegel generieren
friedrich hegel und seine logik des
guten und bösen he gesagt das gute und
böse ist nichts dass er etwas was mit
unseren willen zu tun hat oder unseren
handlungen sondern etwas mit der logik
der begriffe das noch einen ganz anderen
zugang zum guten erlösen und das ist
auch nichts von der theorie die wir auf
jeden fall betrachten lösen dann vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit und bis zur
nächsten sitzung